في مشهد غير مسبوق في تاريخ الديمقراطيه
البرازيليه اقتحم مؤيدونا للرئيس السابق
جرير برسونارو مراكز الحكم الثلاث في
البرازيل القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه
البرازيليه ومجلس النواب الفدرالي
والمحكمه العثيدراليه العليا وذلك رفضا
لانتخابي الرئيس الاسري لولا دا سيلفا
وتنصيبه رئيسا للبلاد بعد خساره الرئيس
السابق بون سونارو ومغادرته للبلاد
السلطه الثلاثه وتحطيمها عدد من المقتنيات
داخل هذه القصور الثلاث بينما كان الرئيس
الاولى ده سيلفا متواجدا هنا في ولايه سوف
طاوله يزوره احدى المدن في الولايه التي
كانت قد تعرضت لكارثه انسانيه لولا ده
سيلفا رفض هذه الاحتجاجات ووصفها
بالانقلابيه ولانها فو يجب رجعها وفق
تعبيره وقام بفرض اجراءات استثنائيه تسمح
للشرطه الفيدراليه والقوات الفيدراليه
بالتدخل في اداره الامن في العاصمه
الفداريه بعد ساعات على الاقتحام قامت
الشرطه المحليه والفيدراليه باستعاده
السيطره على المباني الحكوميه الثلاث
وقامت بترضي المحتاجين من داخل المواقع
والمراكز الرسميه والحكوميه
واعتقل 10 من المحتاجين على ذمه المشاركه
بافعال غير ديمقراطيه وانقلابيه وفقه
تعبيرها
وقام حاكم المقاطعه الفيدراليه بالاعتذار
عن تصرفه
واقالتي وزير الامن المحلي في المقاطعه
الفدراليه فيما قدم اعتذاره على ما جرى في
المقاطعه ورفض بشكل كامل كل الاحداث التي
وسطها بغير الديمقراطيه حسن مسعود الجزيره
سوف اقوله